so hello everybody I would like to
introduce you to jonathan hill jonathan
hill just started a new podcast on
symbolism called the ground and it is
under the authority of st. maximus
weimar who is the heads a monastery in
long island so and i've been in contact
with that monastery for a while father
silouan jason yah know who all of you
know if you follow me I love his work
he's at that monastery so that I I have
a connection to that monastery and I was
really excited to see this new podcast
come up because I feel like there's a
lot of room in this space to talk about
symbolism there are different ways you
know I kind of give you guys one line of
how to look at the world in terms of
symbolism usually space but I feel like
there are different lines to enter into
this and so I'm excited to see where
this this podcast is going to go I
follow Jonathan's blog you know a little
bit once in a while I drop in and he has
a blog called
the what is it the theology of the
beautiful Orthodox theology Orthodox
theology of the beautiful and in that he
talks about symbolism as well usually
really going into the fathers and using
the source text and so it's a really
good it's a really it's a really good
source for people to go to especially
after watching my videos where you feel
like sometimes I'm talking off the cuff
I don't mention the references like I
don't all wait I'm not always saying say
Maximus Saint Ephrem st. Gregory or st.
John of Damascus or whatever but when
you read his blog he really gives you
the references that you can go back into
the father's and and find the sources so
I'm excited to talk to him and yeah
we'll see what he has to say
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so Jonathan tell us a bit about yourself
and maybe about what prompted you to to
create this new podcast great so I am
essentially a spiritual son of father
Maximus by Marr the abbot of the
monastery of st. Denis Caesarea okay
he's my confessor and although I live in
Boise Idaho and he's here in Long Island
we've kept up that relationship and it's
it's even more than just confess Oriole
he's really more of a teacher and most
of everything that I've learned through
orthodoxy has come filtered through him
and I spend a lot of time at this
monastery it's a lot of talks with you
mentioned him father justjust in the
auto or father so on I'm sorry father
Maximus father Basilio's and sitting
around particularly after Matins we
might we serve Matins in the morning at
8 a.m. and I'll be at the chloros as
most people know I also sing opera for a
living and will read something in the
minion or and they will come with the
service will finish and we'll say we'll
have coffee and oftentimes a
conversation about something oh that was
interesting text oh that was an
interesting that was interesting way of
phrasing this I remember in one
particular instance I read a translation
it was quote Jesus the beyond God end
quote
that's a very fascinating statement
Jesus that beyond God okay so we'll look
let's sit down and talk about that would
be something that we would do here at
the monastery and so father Maximus is
introduction into the faith and how we
talk about orthodoxy is is through
symbolism and it's always symbolic and
this is primarily because of this this
content this concept of God as being
beyond being right and so we have to use
these these symbols mainly through words
and through image and you know it's even
I'm even using a symbol right now in my
two hands unifying together right so we
we can't talk about God directly we have
to use these kind of other avenues to
discuss and think and contemplate the
Conte the context of the content of the
faith of Orthodoxy and and of you know
who was the god man
who was the father who was the spirit
what's the Trinity what's the code
what's Christology what's you know what
are we doing in the services and so what
so yeah so tell me a bit about the about
the podcast like what is your cuz I now
the first episode came out last week I
listen to it it was very interesting it
was really kind of a an introduction
like a layman's introduction trying to
get people to enter into these symbolic
space it's I know that it's tough to get
people to enter into that space I face
that all the time I have people I have
people who watch my videos I don't know
why they do it but they say I've been
watching your videos for months and I
didn't know what you were talking about
and then finally I understood it's like
I don't know but prompted you to
continue to listen to my videos that I'm
happy you did when finally you were able
to kind of catch the little get see that
spark or catch that's part so I feel in
the first episode that's what you're
trying to do is trying to like get
people into the right thinking in order
to see what you're gonna talk about
later the the right thinking that's
that's a great way to to phrase it we
wanted to start with something that was
introductory and accessible and and I
mentioned in the up
sewed father Justinian and I father
Justinian the deacon in Bessemer Alabama
we could have started with st. Maximus
ambiguity could have started with
Denise's divine names and we do get to
those later but symbolism is is such an
incredibly complex topic that you're
right it's it's it's very hard to know
where to start so we wanted to start
with something that was accessible and
that something that we do every day we
talk every day we use words every day we
read every day whether it's a text
message and email something online or we
are talking with family members or
friends and so we can come at this this
idea and coming back to what you said
right thinking words are automatically
connected and I'm going to continue to
use this this kind of image they're
automatically connected with a thought
right and the I know using symbolism to
discuss symbolism this is this is a kind
of a silly prospect but you you're when
you talk when you use a word it's
connected to the thought that you have
in your head and we use that example of
a dog if I were to write the word dog on
a page I'm I'm connecting everyone else
who reads that word dog on a page to the
thought that I have right and so now
words are are connecting my thought to
the page in terms of my thought to the
actual three letters do ng but then also
everyone else's thought everyone else
around who's reading do ng s dog but
they're connected to that and then in
that way they're connected to me and
this this is how we actually are
connecting to we're connecting our
thoughts and it's it's so mundane that I
think we can we do it so often we don't
tend to engage with it on the on the
level that I think is appropriate right
because we talking is just so talking
talking talking talking but when we when
we get down to it it's really mysterious
and it's also miraculous we can
communicate hidden thoughts in our heads
to someone else that is a great mystery
and really honestly a great miracle yeah
well I think I think that you're right
and that when you talk about taking it
for granted I think that's a really
important point
make with people and it's we're almost
in a in a situation that's different
let's say from the situation of the
fathers and it's a very special
situation where as the types of things
we're talking about when we talk about
symbolism it was taken for granted in
their world and so a lot of people ask
me you know like I'll point them let's
say to a text which has symbolism like
now you know st. Gregory Mesa life of
Moses and they'll say no I want you to
do don't you have a text from the
fathers that explain symbolism like I
don't there isn't really that much of a
text that explains symbolism because for
them it was just taken for granted we
have to explain symbolism today because
we've been through a whole period of
time where meaning has been assaulted
where the you know where there's been
this whole deconstructed movement this
whole assault on on meaning and the
relationship between meaning and the
world and so now we're in a situation
where we have to now go back into the
fathers text and explain how the
symbolism occurs and so we're in a
different situation and it accounts it
accounts I think it helps to account for
why we have to speak the way we're
speaking today which is we have to
explain symbolism and and so it is a
unique moment but in a way there's a
richness to that as well which is that
because we've we've kind of the were the
world of symbolism has been assaulted
and has come very close to dying then
there's a place where we can sit we can
stand and we can look at it from a
little bit of a distance in order to be
able to perceive it and hopefully to be
able to plunge back in because like you
said it's inevitable the types of things
this symbolic coming together that you
mentioned that the coming together of
the words and or the letters to form
words and the words to form sentences
all this happening and the coming
together of the people who are accepting
of this language okay if we if we accept
the language then we are every time I
say the word dog to you I'm in communion
with you like there's a desire to to
search for a communal understanding and
there can be equivocation it's possible
but but there is also the possibility of
finding of finding that communal
communion um so so I I think it's I
think that the work
helping people see that is what I've
seen it I've seen that for some people
it's really been a light in the darkness
like it's been a way for them to finally
say oh that's what this is about like
all this Christian stuff that I did that
every that I just thought was just silly
nonsense a bunch of silly stories like
oh it's actually talking about reality
what I to come back to a statement you
said I don't think we have to truly
worry about symbolism dying no in a real
way because destroy itself it could be
the end of the world wouldn't exist
actually communication wouldn't exist
language we communicate symbolically
even now when we communicate using my um
using hand gestures I'm not just using
text I'm using a symbol you're seeing an
image I'm creating an image that this
image of communion that you then know
and and so in a way like something like
sign language which is extremely image
related is a great way to look at this
or if we were to - okay so my wife is
Taiwanese okay and so she speaks she
speaks upwards of five languages
Mandarin Taiwanese Cantonese a little
German and in English now I'm learning
Mandarin so I can talk to my my
father-in-law and my mother-in-law and
in but in learning Mandarin you really
learn that each character is a symbol I
mean a real thing yeah right and so the
when you have a word like power power is
that is is two characters put together
I'm sorry man is two characters put
together it's rice field and then
underneath it is power and the reason is
because man is the power of the rice
field
he's the one who's whose actual izing
that right that that symbol right so
every time we communicate we're bringing
our thought like into being yeah and
it's being circumscribed by that by the
word right and you've talked a lot about
this too about
Vails veils conceal and reveal things
right and so words words are both
concealing the thought that we have yeah
but it's also concealing the thought
that we have yeah for sure one of the
things that it's interesting that you
mentioned Mandarin and one of the ìiî
sometimes I wonder if one of the reasons
why this is like a long long story but
one of the reasons why we came to have a
kind of alienation in terms of meaning
is that ancient languages like Chinese
Hebrew Arabic all have a higher there's
a higher glyphic element to the to their
letters and so the letters are actually
formed either geometrically or they're
formed in a way that is that is
meaningful whereas because you know
because Greek and Latin adopted another
alphabet to represent their language
there's like a weird dis junk which
happened and so the type of
interpretation that you see for example
and do a tradition where they actually
break apart like they'll break apart
words and look at like you did with
mandarin they'll look at the letters and
look at this letter means this this
letter means that and that's why those
letters are brought together in order to
make a word me it's we can't really do
that in our languages and so we have a
we have an we have a difficulty in which
it seems like meaning is arbitrary in
our language like it seems like we just
have these letters that are arbitrary
and these sounds that are arbitrary but
but but it's if you dig a little bit you
can find like there even some people
doing some research now on words I say
word sonority and trying to show that
there are certain types of words that
all have the same type of soon sonority
like certain like let's say if you have
a lot of hard consonants in a word that
it it actually it might be related to
the meaning of the word that inevitably
we tend to find sounds that relate to
the word it's not universal but that
there is something like if you look if
you look at old words for example you
find that connection which is which is
somewhat long I mean an enemy I don't
remember the exact linguistic term
and not to delve too much into us but
there is that was it
onomatopoeia where the word sounds like
the thing what it is yeah
right and so like the word break right
rake you you hear the the actual thing
that's happening in the word
yeah that's across many many English
words yeah and I but yeah so I think
that guiding into those types of things
which in terms of language it can help
us see that at least at the at the
origin language would have been very
more organic and more related to the
actual meaning and then there's a
there's a kind of you see that in some
of the Christian traditions I'm oldest
idea that no the language of God was
this direct language that was a mediated
by that wasn't artificially mediated you
could say that it was direct reality
like when God spoke it is reality like
there's no meet wait and then there's
the offers of mediation which which kind
of add themselves with time and with the
fall you get the sense of that well I
talked about the garments of skin that
language also has these garments of
skins which were which were added in
their structure you know to to help them
survive in the complicated world but
also it's harder to see the the meaning
at some point it's harder to see the
connection to a deeper felt meaning you
say something like that
well even here when previously a few
minutes ago when we're talking about
words bringing things into being and
words coming into being
bringing thoughts into being you know
and you talk about the Lord spoke
things came to be right I mean we've
that's what song song 32 and it's red
and the hours were right before Matins
or you know in the beginning the Lord
spoke God spoke right so this this
concept of speaking and and things
coming to be and we share we share that
relationship we share that image
we've gone right because God made us in
this image to be able to bring things
into being in in in a pattern right in
this this this relationship right and
father they're sitting and I it takes a
few a few episodes we to get there but
we we ended we end up start talking
about how words are really sacramental
in this way right and we have to be very
careful about how we use words and you
care about what meaning we're trying to
we're trying to convey and and shape to
to really bring about like the proper
ordering yeah right so things are
twisted yeah and we're in a good space
where we're in a good space to
understand that in the sense that I
always see you know with like guys look
at our kind of degenerated world and I
always always see also has an
opportunity like there seems to be an
opportunity right now because everybody
can notice let's say in the news or in
the media that their tether attempting
to to actually shape reality with the
way they talk about things and so they
they speak about an event and they that
you can see that the words are carefully
chosen and carefully articulated in
order to shape the actual event and so
they can see that there's a certain
malleability to an event you know
because there are so many things you
could talk about you know there's a
million ways you could talk about the
same event and so not that it's
subjective but that you can twist things
you can say things in a way that will
make the event that will they create the
event in people's understanding and will
change the narrative you're shooting
perception yeah so people we can see it
everybody sees it because it happens on
both sides of the political aisle
and you've right you could at least see
it in your enemy if you can't see it in
your on your own side you can lease your
enemy do it so maybe you it'd be good to
know that you or your side does it as
well but the fact that we can see that
it can help us understand how language
is important how primordial it is and
how right speaking actually can have a
crazy effect on the world like it can
actually it can actually be part of
making the world whole making the world
a good place if you can speak you can
speak truth and you can speak well you
can even sex well what's that sense
speak truth to power right so like how
we actualize it would our ability to
communicate an hour right because if you
if you communicate improperly you're
twisting that communion but we talked
about how communication is is really a
communion and so you we can either have
a perverted communion or we can have one
that is honest and true and and a loving
community so you know like people who
try to play games with words or they
purposely try to mix people up you know
I have to like no you're not really
taking this seriously right yeah what we
do it everybody does it I do it all the
time I do with my wife she doesn't with
me talking to my wife and I'll say
something like this is why you did this
and so I want to put intentions in her
like I want you I want to put her
intentions in her in order to validate
my story right mm-hmm
and she will have to like defend herself
and be like no that's not why that's not
you don't know the reasons why I did
this you can see the result but the
reason is not is hidden from you but
it's like no I want to put that seed
there so it validates my so I can twist
the world to my image you know and so we
do it all the time it's a it's our it's
our it's a horrible habit that we have
and unlike do it a million times more
what and this I'm glad you brought this
up this is um when we think about the
content of idolatry we're not just
talking about a statute or a picture
that we're bowing down because because
the word right because we have this
union of language and
right and that's and that's the the the
ontological reality is union of language
and image right it's a real image our
thoughts are a real image that we use to
we can use them for good or we can use
them for evil right and we can bow down
and worship our thoughts or we can
become you know as the father's and as
it seems to be transparent vessels to to
let the truth kind of flow through right
so that other people can come into the
light you know so it's this this kind of
embracing of intelligibility this way
this is this is where like father
Justinian and I have have grounded
intent the the whole pot you know this
is where we start right but you have you
income to come back again you worry this
so perfectly right thinking right
orthodoxy is Right galore it's right
worship right so we have to we have to
have proper thoughts with they have and
and put them in the proper order right
in order to in order to arrive at this
reality or we'll have like a false
impression of what what's going on yeah
yeah I want to switch the subject a
little bit one of the things in your in
the podcast the first episode which
which was put up that I find interesting
is that you reference a book you read
the book the universe as symbol in sign
I think the name of the book is and I
several people have told me that I
really need to read this and it's on my
reading list I haven't gone to it and I
and I know that I've even received
emails from people asked me why don't
you recommend this book and it's a
contemporary book written by an orthodox
saint like why don't you recommend it
it's very simple is like I just haven't
read it and so I know hey I can't
recommend it until I've read it I will
read it but maybe you can tell a little
bit people a little bit about it so that
they can get their recommendation from
you
so it's a it's a book I was introduced
to by father Max my father Maximus
mainly because I was in a place where
[Music]
I couldn't apprehend what st. Maximus
was saying or I couldn't comprehend what
st. Ignatius was saying and what he says
in the beginning about about words is so
again if it's it's it's like it's always
been there but then when you hear it in
a certain way it becomes this big like
light bulb oh that that's the thing they
were talking about right and so putting
he talks about you know children
learning letters right and we we focus
so much when when we're learning how to
how to do language how to communicate in
language you focus so much on this is an
i this is an N this is an M right and
but we don't necessarily know how to put
them together and then now later
you know the 3rd 4th 5th grade we're
putting them together and we're making
bigger words and were and this is how
like we approach the symbolic life but
that if we continue to to apprehend the
world as as just letters right this is
this is I this is N and not actually
symbolizing them for the higher meaning
then we're conscious constantly existing
at this kind of first grade level of
interacting with the world and so that
that's like his first chapter and he
actually quotes st. Maximus in st. Denis
s I don't have the clothes on me at the
hand but very very good a very solid
kind of introduction into them too and
and after after that first chapter he
goes on it gets a little he talks about
different ways that we can understand
things like rocks or trees or animals
and and I and I think that this is kind
of how we generally approach symbolism
by saying like the raucous is foundation
ok the rock is firm the rock is the rock
is heavy right so we have the the
raucous foundations that we're drawing
an analogy right the rock is
foundational it's like Christ great the
rock is heavy it's like judgment and but
but it's also being right so so the rock
symbolizes by by merely
existing this theophany of being no I
mean maybe just to ask you a question
like that's that's been really my my
approach in the sense that I I tell
people look at the phenomenal
phenomenological experience of something
you know like a rock you have a
phenomenological experience of something
not it's not its scientific composition
but how you experience it and then that
will help you understand what it means
and what it will end up meaning in
stories because that's what people had
to deal with like they're they're
talking about Iraq they're going to have
it use in a way that makes sense in the
human world of interactions like you can
use a rock to throw at someone but you
can also like you said build a rock on
on on build something on a rock and then
it hold so it's like that those are
actual characteristics of the of the
thing as we experience them right so so
before where we have symbolism as being
like a union of language and image here
we have symbolism being a union of
sensible and intelligent yeah right so
so sensible is what I mean by sensible
it is like a real object right so if I
have like a real icon right and then an
intelligible it would be like it's shiny
right the shiny is the thing that comes
like through the icon because shiny
doesn't actually exist on its own shiny
is that thing that we see like they
would see the icon is shiny the rock is
rough the dog's fur is smooth right so
those kind of things that we we
intellect right we they don't exist
really on there only exists in another
thing and then that thing that object
exists with with by being intelligible
right and so the dog exists by being
furry the rock exists by being rough all
the qualities of things
and so the the you know we're saying
that like symbolism when I say that a
rock is firm I'm actually saying that
the rock is firm it's not just some like
analogy all right no I know it I mean
right right it's not just like like a
metaphor in the way that people use this
idea of it it's just like it's
arbitrarily it's arbitrary saying
signifying something else I get
arbitrarily signifying something it's
not arbitrary it's like it's the actual
characteristics of the thing you're
manifesting a universal pattern it's not
it's not it's not arbitrary or
subjective at all right right so if we
come back to this technique oh I book he
goes through kind of these natural
symbols and we have to get to that in
episode 2 of the podcast and then and
and I mean I mean how these natural
symbols also relate to each other right
so so Iraq is being and then a plant is
also being but a plant has this thing
called life it grows and it multiplies
and they wither isn't it decays but it's
still being in the sense that it's it
still exists right and so there's this
union but then there's also this
difference and then in animals he goes
on to talk about animals and dim
intellection or animal of mine reason
which are also beings that then also
have life but then they also have mind
and now you you so you have this Union
this constant union and and and
distinction this he doesn't but he also
has like an ontological he explains that
ontological hierarchy of of mind right
right and so and so we get we ended this
a lot more in the next episode but yes
it is it is to this right you know rocks
life animal life man and he'll go he'll
go into you know in what in one of my
blog pieces I talk about the like the
olive oil being virtue and virtue how is
olive oil virtuous well I that's just a
total riff on Saint Nick alone let's
paste that and and he goes into more
Christian simple
it goes into a lot of the cross and and
some other Christian symbols which we
also will touch on you are you gonna be
going through the book basically like
using it as a track so so Father
Justinian did not want to do essentially
a book review right yeah we just want to
use it as kind of an introduction
essentially just the word part the word
part is so deep the rest of the book is
actually kind of mundane and pretty easy
to follow a raucous foundation tree is
that kind of that's pretty pretty
self-explanatory but the word the
introduction of the words and how they
connect to thoughts and pudding you have
to put thoughts together properly like
you put letters together properly and
right but worse together properly
grammatically deform a little sentence
so that you can actually convey
something right we're not Yoda right we
have we have to be like this is kind of
like symbolism right because symbolism
gets a bad rap which game right oh
you're just making stuff up well no like
Stella is real letters are real words
are real and they have they have
boundaries and they're properly
delineated
yeah and you don't have been a word like
a sentence you don't think that it's a
game if you can you can make a word in a
sentence the sentence will say the
opposite of the other sentence the word
is still in the sentence it doesn't mean
that it's are but it doesn't mean that
it's just a game that I'm making it up
it just means that there's a grammar and
if you if and the grammar depending on
the relationship of the different
symbols then they'll mean they'll
they'll end up ultimately pointing to
something different something at
something else you know
it's like I tell people like they're
know cuz that because everybody gets
into the whole you know symbolism is
satanic and you know you get these kind
of Protestant these weird Protestant
Orthodox like they're like Orthodox but
they have a weird Protestant way of
thinking where they see all symbolism is
evil somehow they don't see that we have
all the symbolism in our church and so
you know they it's if they see a
pentagram it's like a pentagram is evil
like a Peter Graham is not evil
pentagram is this a five pointed star I
mean right it's the evil if it's used in
a context that is evil but yes I keep
saying it's like you know Christ with
the four glories that's a pentagram my
friend
that's four points for it five that's
four points with that point at the top
that gets the same structure so if
there's nothing wrong but it can be like
an upside-down cross can be an image of
st. Peter but it can also be an
antichrist image it just depends on the
sentence in which that symbol is placed
that can help you understand what it's
pointing to and what it's trying to
erase the if it's the meaning that
they're projecting onto that symbol the
symbol itself is not okay that there are
no symbols that are evil like they're
not nothing in creation is evil in
itself you know it's the accumulate you
can accumulate certain imageries in a
way that will obviously be the evil but
it doesn't mean that the individual like
the elements themselves are are evil
because right it just meaning they're
just elements of meaning the Satan the
devil can only twist and and and pervert
but he can't create anything right and
and we know this because in Genesis it
says that everything is good yeah
everything is imbued with goodness and
and that's actually how everything
existed this this is a little complex
and it would off the tangent but this
this whole pre-christian Hellenic idea
which definitely the fathers picked up
in the uses and maximus is this idea of
everything existing by the goodness by a
good right but by its by its beauty this
is that idea so and that's not really
here there but yeah but it no but it's
important it's important because what's
important is because one of the
accusations that we get at least in the
Orthodox Church and in America I mean
the cat Catholicism as well is that you
know because people can see connections
like they can actually see let's a
visual connection between symbolism of
the witches in the church and symbolism
that was there before Christianity let's
say and they can see that there's a
there's a link a visual link or a an
analogical link we'll say well look at
how evil traditional Christianity is
because it takes things from these evil
culture then it's like that's not how it
works
it has to work that way that's not how
the image of the image of a mother and a
child even though you had the image of
Isis doesn't mean that it's evil because
the image of a mother and a child
is in the image of your wife with her
child it's it's it's a universal image
that actually to just and to show you
how Universal is to bring it back to
Mandarin the character in Mandarin for
good is mother with child oh yeah
awesome
but that is how right so because a
mother with child is good Yeah right
continues the culture it continues the
you know and also it's the incarnation
right so Theo tacos with child this is
good right so yeah and it's the image of
everything it's like the seed and the
world it's you know it's like that let's
say that especially them usually the
child is male so it's like the let's say
the seed and the the body it's like they
you know the hidden part and the
manifestation so it's like a you can't
get there are very few images that are
more powerful than the image of a child
on the lap of his mother like know
obviously that image will then become to
be used in order to manifest the highest
revelation of that which is the mother
of God and Christ that's that is the
most complete revelation of the imagery
which existed yeah it existed in Egypt
and in Babylon and all these other
cultures because they're it's just it's
just an image of reality but it exists
it there because it has to yeah right
world is not going to exist it's gonna
it's gonna the world for the world to
exist there has to be this symbolic key
symbolic structure right because this is
how we communicate this is this and and
that's we bring words into being and we
communicate by through and we
communicate a symbolic structure
symbolically the world is is a symbolic
structure that's order properly and then
we embrace it understanding that order
and then we communicate properly that
order and again that's all wrapped up in
the context of the logos right who is
the ultimate symbol of language the word
and the image the image of the Father
right and becoming flesh so the images
the flushes of the word becomes flesh
right this image of he now the
incarnation is this is this hypostatic
divine human reality of a word and flesh
right of language and image
and they're together in this one reality
yeah and that's it ends up say I can't
when I think about the incarnation I
keep saying I'm the one hand it it's
like it's an impossible crazy thing it's
it's it's it's this wild it's like it's
sacrilegious to think about it
everything about it is it destroy is
disturbing but then when you when you
kind of enter into it you realize that
it wait it's actually it's actually the
key to reality it's actually showing us
how everything exists right it's only
it's only kind of condon its condensing
it into this one this one moment and
this one image that has everything into
it but like I said that at the same time
it's that's why it also is it kind of
breaks all the categories it it's it's
it's there's something about it which is
too much too too big too much it just
it's just shattering but then it is at
the same time the key to everything
it's a kilo of how we get in and st.
Maximus actually even says this in the
first century on the theology of the Sun
number 66 that the Incarnation is the
key to understanding all arcane
symbolism yeah just done yeah exactly
know for sure for sure no I think I've
quoted that before to that exact quote
III
I love st. Maximus obviously I think I'm
not hiding I'm not hiding that from
anybody but uh but yeah so I'm really
look I'm really looking forward to
seeing where this is gonna go I I'm
excited to to find other Orthodox people
kind of entering explicitly into this
space like I mean Orthodox priests and
Orthodox people talk about symbolism all
the time you know in the way they
interact with the liturgy and the church
and everything but I'm happy to see
something explicitly that is going to be
helping people understand that so I
would really encourage people to to go
to the podcast to to check it out and
also to check out the book the is the
universe as sign and symbol I think it's
simple and sign I always get them mixed
up if you google that Google will fix it
for you there's also a link to it on on
our Facebook page all right so I will
put up all those links in on of your of
your blog and your podcast and
everything will be in the description of
this video so guys check it out and what
we'll do I think two is I'll let a few
episodes go
maybe you know if you have like a season
or something well I'll be following it
and hopefully you know if you are in the
symbolic world group I would suggest
like you post it there and try to
encourage people to discuss some of the
things you talked about in the in the
group as well and maybe after you've
done it it's like several a pearls
episode we can we can do this again and
oh perfect thank you very much get a
sense of where you went with it great
alright so I'm definitely looking
forward to to seeing what you guys put
out there thank you very much this was
this was a great time great discussion
all right Jonathan it was good to talk
to you thank you take care if you enjoy
the symbolic world content there's a lot
of things you can do to help us out if
you're not subscribed please do go ahead
and share this to all your friends if
you can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com